hello they shouldn't be left out in the
open oh where's he putting Tinsley does
client confidentiality mean nothing to
you
everybody's just gonna come grab that
tinsel pick up and Tinsley's a bad
employee
oh
wait a minute
I see a storm Cyclops
we got the Friday the MCU no these are
not in the ends
burn the Frog man
[Music]
throw them in the bottom of a swamp
welcome back to New rockstars she all
proves that with the right thing you
must acquit though it's a low stakes
side adventure and a trademark disputes
leading to the coming arrival of Matt
Murdoch Daredevil in the MCU and in this
video we're gonna react to that and some
exclusive footage of Daredevil and
shields showing at d23 also stick around
to see Mt celebrate the arrival of
Broadway and police MC Eugene we're here
baby this is inside Marvel new
Rockstar's official after show for
She-Hulk I'm Eric Boss with me is Mt and
Jessica Clemens good morning friends
good morning Eric I'm so happy this
episode was so much fun I loved it oh
why was it so much fun why did you love
it empty
out of the ball pogging Nikki
Nikki most importantly we have the
arrival of Eugene batillo to the MCU
frog band making a quick Cameo I'm so
happy
it's such a fun Cameo too he's just
soapy puddled by that elevator uh super
fun I in my opinion I think this episode
of the five that have been released so
far might be my least favorite it's just
a little uneventful just kind of a
vibing episode overall I'm still
enjoying the show because it's just like
it's a fun vibe like I'm loving these
characters and loving living in this
world
um but now it just seems like based on
this episode I don't know if Titania is
the main villain of the series I don't
know if the main conflict of the series
is like human versus human or if it's
human Versus Society if it's human
versus nature right now it seems like a
mix between human versus human and human
versus society in general or really
human versus human like human versus
self right like I just don't really know
what Jen wants like I don't know what
she's going after in the series she's
just kind of a reactionary character
who's just kind of like waiting for
things to happen to her but overall I
I'm enjoying it I think the
restructuring of the Season kind of
feels like it they had to take stuff out
of this midpoint episode because I don't
know we needed 24 minutes of like Jen
just like making sure she could use the
name She-Hulk as
but I enjoyed it it did feel kind of
like a fluffer episode for its own show
but it was also it is it was my least
favorite as well I think last episode
was my favorite but I do think the
battle is gonna be with and what we saw
at the end of this episode more so
She-Hulk fighting herself that was the
one part of this episode that I did
really like was after Arthur came to
stand and talked and it was just clear
that like Jen is going to be fighting
herself in different ways than Bruce did
hers will be just like in just herself
it'd be gen V Jen and so I was like oh
this is sad and I really am interested
in this but the rest I was like
okay yeah all right I agree I think uh
that was probably my favorite part of
the episode in addition to just like pug
and Nikki just like talking about shoes
I I genuinely enjoyed that I really
liked that they brought back the dates
because at first I was like well I know
they're gonna bring back Todd but the
fact that all four of them got to come
back and testify like the Seinfeld
finale like it was just fun to go back
through that list and and have another
moment with each of those characters and
for them to play like a plot role
instead of just like a World building
role I thought that was really clever I
love that well let's actually recap the
whole episode so the episode begins with
Jen drowning and Titania's commercials
for her She-Hulk branded skincare and
wellness products on TV Billboards on
the Sunset Strip which are not cheap my
friends it's Prime Primo real estate uh
but also for some radio ads cousin Chad
bought boxes and boxes of these things
he just breaks into her house like I'm
here I Jen lock your goddamn door lock
your damn door it's like third time's
the charm it's gonna be someone bad the
next time the next time it's gonna be
something like I could just walk in here
what it's like uh taking a step back in
security to prove a point to her dad
he's like trying to set up he's like
buried stuff in the yard which I think
are landmines I think that's some
station 11 landmines
but no like she's like okay well just to
prove him wrong I'm turning the clock
back to 1950 where we didn't need to
lock our doors but you know 1950 was bad
for most most people on human Earth so
yeah lock your doors please
and cuts and shed probably just knows
where she keeps the key that's my theory
uh but he graciously begins to mansplain
trademark law to his lawyer cousin
that's nice thanks Chad classic Chad Jen
and Nikki confront Titania at an event
where Titania finally speaks we get to
hear Jamila Jamil's American accent I
want to hear your thoughts uh both of
you what did you think of her voice here
did you not like it she was nervous
about it she even posted on Twitter and
was like oh no they're gonna hear my
American accent and I was like you did
great with a valley girl accent I yeah
she did really great yeah I thought it
was accurate I just think like the
character choice is just like oh I get
why why jyn hates her because it's such
like an annoying value
Girl whole influencer she is literally
when she says thank you I was like oh
this is Kim Kardashian I was like oh
this is
yeah that's that's all to me literally
had to do is just like watch E watch the
E network for like I don't know a couple
days and then she's got it you know that
character seems really fun it's like a a
really bad sober version of Madison uh
it's like it's like yeah this is silly
this is fun I bet she's having fun it's
just oh yeah wasn't there like some
press video where like Madison just
shoves Titania out of the way it's like
yes
we want to live with this and give her
at least like a a four episode spin-off
series please please so pug asks Nikki
to stand in line with him for the Iron
Man 3 sneaker drop and I love that these
came back that that's so fun he wants
two pairs one to rock one a stock she
agrees the Pug will introduce her to his
drip broker they go to a boba Cafe
secretly a friend for a superhero
clothing business I don't I guess this
wouldn't need to be a secret right
because otherwise like the dodc would be
cracking down on this I was wondering
why this needed to be a friend like why
they had to be so hush about it but he
uh at first the Barista reveals a bunch
of knockoff MCO merch for the Avengers
and the Avengers which is fun like it it
feels like oh look out epic hero shop
you got some competitors around and we
make that shirt I'm not going to wear it
yo I would rock that I love it I wish I
had it eventually they're able to book
an appointment with the real clothing
designer uh Mr Holloway wants a She-Hulk
ads to stop even though we see him
trying one of those booty boost
smoothies at the in the end credits do
we think he was just disappointed with
like the results of the booty boost
he wasn't happy he wasn't smiling he was
like sulking that his butt is still flat
understandable yeah but the other uh
like who is that Dennis or whatever was
giving like some look like
why are you doing this in the office do
this at all
I read something different
yeah I get it I feel it I support it
hallway teams of Jen with Mallory book
to fight titanium court and as she walks
into the courtroom Titanic it's my
favorite MCU burn of nice suit Shrek
yeah I cracked out man cracked up I was
so offended for her especially because
I'm dumb and it was my first time
hearing that comparison about She-Hulk
and so I was like I was like what's
wrong with you I was like that's almost
racist I was like what are you doing
what are you saying I was like wait did
you see what she posted on Twitter she
was like hashtag Shrek on keto yeah
and she also said uh what did she say
she said uh more like uh oh my gosh she
said a bunch of dirty shady [ __ ] Titania
on Twitter it's just going off right now
and I'm here for it she is the best I
love her I just love that Shrek exists
in the MCU I know all pop pop culture at
this point exists in the MCU but like
Shrek is here and Shrek is life and I'm
so happy so Mallory argues that the name
She-Hulk did not exist in the public
discourse before Jen became a public
figure and Titania's lawyer argues that
Jen initially wanted nothing to do with
the name the judge says that Jim will
need to show a pattern of her using that
name of She-Hulk they end up meeting
with the designer Luke Jacobson uh which
randomly is the name of a nobody
character in Marvel Dakota North issues
of 1986 I don't think there's any
connection here but obviously Luke is
shaping up to be like an Edna Mode type
figure for the MCU Far Cry from Melvin
Potter but uh Luke has a bit of flair to
his designs and we're here for it
um now Mt you spotted this last night I
actually did not see this at first but
walking out past them carrying a
clothing bag is Brandon Stanley as
Eugene patilio who is playing LeapFrog
on this show slash frog man who knows
I'm so excited I'm like my goodness like
I saw the back of that dude's head I was
like that is Eugene that is my my
brother that is the Frog God it is time
for the MCU to enter level two we were
at level one we are entering level two
Everything Has Changed I'm so excited
yeah and like we were joking about this
on Twitter but like the physical comedy
that Brandon is doing in the background
just like uh do I oh wait he's like over
here uh he's so confused by that
elevator doing getting so much out of
just like the back of his head like I'm
so excited to see this guy next week he
was looking for Crime that's what he
that's why he was like a crime here
he was so damn lost it also clearly had
to be his first time in that building
because how the hell is going to get
lost every single time oh did he leap in
from the window and now he's I think he
did he was like yeah no I just think he
was picking up the suit for someone else
but I think it's still funny
I cannot wait to see his personality in
action he reminded me when I was a PA
and I had to go pick up like a laundry
dry cleaning deliveries and just trying
to get out of any building because in
Los Angeles when you go to these nice
places in Beverly Hills or downtown you
have to take an elevator it's like a
high-rise and you have to like punch in
what floor or what suite you're going to
and it's not easy to navigate so I I
just I still can't get to my dentist I
always forget Which floor it is it's
like on the 12th of 13. and then I get
lost and then I'm late and they get mad
at me but it's okay my teeth are great
and they go harder on your teeth
punching me in the jaw and Jen realizes
Todd from last week is another one of
Mallory's clients Aha and he basically
dresses like a DC EU likes Luther so
keep an eye on it basically
Shady uh for sure he's coming back Jen
uses her matcher dates to prove a
pattern of using the She-Hulk name so
David ortunga returns as Derek we also
see Todd and Noah and Arthur the judge
rules and Jen's favor titanium must
recall all the products so Jen returns
to Luke's shop and tries on some new
suits along with a special one that will
likely be her white and purple stretchy
suit that we've seen in trailers and we
see another suit another one of his
clients is the devil of Hell's Kitchen
Matt Murdoch who for some reason flies
from New York to LA to get his suit made
it's probably not worth going too crazy
over all this but uh in the closing
credits art pug shoots includes designs
matching Cyclops Ben Graham uh
Spider-Man Deadpool there's a Green
Goblin one in there like Jen or Jess I
assume you're going to be breaking all
these down in the breakdown yeah I'm
just gonna I'm gonna say what they all
are but I'm not gonna get into detail
and please don't get too excited about
them showing up in the MCU
I don't want everyone to go I don't want
everyone's hopes up immediately it's
gonna they're gonna show up eventually
uh my hopes are already up I need to see
speedball immediately yeah
speedball would probably show up way
before Wolverine will
oh God please don't come at me but I'm
just being honest you guys it's gonna be
a couple years it's gonna be a couple
years yeah I think so I mean technically
it is our first Deadpool reference in
the MCU like an overt reference and
anything that we've seen in the MCU but
you know unless something shows up
during the run time of an episode I
don't know if we can call it confirmed
MCU can and I think when it's just in
the credits art like this is just meant
to be fun but in the meantime there's
plenty to talk about here from Daredevil
to LeapFrog to Hulk tide these guys
showing up in the weeks ahead but before
we get into that Mt why you hit us with
that merge plug yeah but guys guys
should have head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab our latest
Obsession shirts Lady Justice inspired
by the She-Hulk attorney at law program
the shirt is limited edition and when
you purchase it you unlock the ability
to get a custom shout out that will
appear right here on inside Marvel so
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome amazing merch options over
at New rockstarmerch.com and let's dive
into the episode Jess you got the
question yeah why is Daredevil getting a
new suit where in his timeline is Matt
Murdock yeah I think that's a real
question of Daredevil right like the
final shot of the episode reveals that
one of the clients of designer Luke
Jacobson must be Matt Murdoch Daredevil
as we see his new gold tinted mask in a
box poor pickup now trailer footage has
shown gen meeting Matt wearing that mask
in this new suit and we've seen Promos
in which Matt tells Jen quote I think
you're in a unique position to do some
real good Jen Walters can use a lot of
help people when Society fails them she
all can help people when the law fails
them now Matt is unmasked in that scene
so Jen is going to be one of the few
people who know Matt's alter ego and a
secret identity I was lucky to attend
t20p last week I got to see the
exclusive footage of Daredevil and
She-Hulk and here's my description of it
just so we're all on the same page Jen
is de-powered on a rooftop with
Daredevil he is wearing his suit they're
perching on this rooftop it looks like
it's a building with a neon sign reading
lily pads I might be wrong about that
but they're trying to get a head count
of the goons down below and then they
get in a little debate over what's a
goon what's a henchman what's the
difference and Matt tells Jen that a
henchman does what he does because he
believes in the cause whereas a goon
just does it for the money Matt is able
to count 18 and Jen's like how are you
able to do that and he reveals while I'm
counting their heart beats and Jen's
skeptical so Matt listens to her
heartbeat and says that it's racing and
they lean in close they almost kiss but
Jen snaps out of it and Matt tells Jen
to let him handle the goons because he
has more experience and then he
somersaults off the ledge based off of
this scene and based off of everything
else we know about Daredevil in the MCU
the big question with Daredevil in this
universe is how much this guy's history
is connected to what we saw him go
through in the Netflix series and by
extension in the way his character
connects to all the other Netflix
defenders in that Universe well Charlie
Cox was asked about this at d23 after
the Daredevil Born Again moment on the
d23 stage and he said he hasn't yet seen
any scripts for Daredevil born again I
don't think they've finished writing
anything they haven't gotten into his
hands yet but then went on to say this
and let's roll the clip my feeling is
based on the title born again I think
that it's the sense is it's going to be
a new beginning it's going to be
different it's going to be tonally
different it's going to be news stories
and new ideas it and and it's just like
Kevin said it's a season one it's not
season four so it's a whole new thing
which is I think the right way to go you
know like if you're gonna do it again
let's do it let's do it differently and
I just want to say before everyone yells
at me that we loved the Netflix
Daredevil we loved it so much that
earlier this year we went back to break
down that first season we adore the show
we love what Charlie Cox did on it and
nothing Charlie Cox said in that quote
or what he cited Kevin feige as saying
erases what the character went through
in Daredevil seasons one two and three
on Netflix but I think what they are
saying is that the 616 MCU Daredevil
probably will not reference the events
of that series at least not explicitly I
think Kevin feige is going to do what he
always does it just kind of keeps it
vague and a little jokey and it'll make
like vague allusions to it but they're
not gonna say in this year at this time
we fought Frank Castle he had that trial
and then Karen Page did this and then
Ben Eric died I don't think they're
going to specifically reference any of
those things because it would just
confuse too much with the MCU timeline
uh but I do think we'll get some vague
nods to Daredevil and Kingpin saying
things like we have a history Mr Murdoch
you know I but I don't think they're
going to cite any specific event or
character that is specific to the
Netflix world I think the bigger names
like John bernthball Punisher Kristen
Ritter Jessica Jones will likely cross
over too but I think the supporting
characters might get recast and I think
they should for a lot of them like Ben
Urich was killed off way too early in
that series I think they probably should
redo the arc with the hand I don't think
I mean maybe some people are attached
with what they did to the hand I know
the Nobu actor is not so like it'd be a
great opportunity to redo a lot of this
um and do it right and based on the way
Matt Murdoch mentors Jen in the way that
he was already an established lawyer
with hidden powers in Spider-Man no way
home and that Cameo and in the deleted
scene with happy Hogan it tells us that
this Matt Murdock has already been
Daredevil for quite some time we're not
going to see an origin story for this
character even though it's gonna be a
season one I don't think it's gonna be a
year one he's not being born he's being
born again this is you know it's a
reference to the Frank Miller 1986 run
of the character so why is he in La I
think he's in LA because of some of the
[ __ ] that's
backstory he's getting a new suit
because I assume his old one got damaged
but he can't get Melvin Potter to hook
him up with a new one probably because
Kingpin is active and running the show
in New York we know that he's got the
eye patch we saw him on stage he's going
back an echo he's still active I think
he's blocking Matt I think he's
sabotaging Matt I think he's ruining
Matt's life in various ways so Matt is
temporarily on the west coast seeking
gear that has not been tainted by Wilson
fisk's reach that's my theory for why
he's over here he has to get out of New
York at least for the time being I
definitely feel like in terms of like
this new like season one comment of like
for Daredevil born again I personally
think that we're probably dealing with a
Multiverse type of situation where
Daredevil was brought in from the
Netflix Universe 2616 and like he has
all the experiences from the Netflix
universe but like now he's in 616. he's
like all right
same [ __ ] I guess they got the same
people like it's it maybe he doesn't
really realize it but like or maybe he
does but like I just feel like he
himself is unique it's like all right
I'm the same guy but like I'm in a new
world so I'm gonna do new stories I'm
gonna have a new interaction with this
new Kingpin and all these uh players and
um I think that that's Marvel's way of
potentially saving what was what
happened to him in the Netflix stuff and
like keeping that but like moving
forward in an MCU Direction
um so do you think we're gonna get a
morbius uh post credit scene with
vulture style glow of just operating
into the MCU like what is this gonna
look like I I definitely feel like
something like that must have happened I
feel like some Multiverse thing is going
on and like it's gonna tie into that
whole narrative
um because like it's it'd be really it'd
be a bummer if it was a new Matt Murdoch
because like everyone would be like oh
man what about the Netflix stuff but
like I just feel like Marvel Studios
probably can't
um like borrow like Netflix story stuff
they can take Charlie Cox but like I
feel like whatever Netflix did is like
their thing like to this day
leave off where season three ended if
that makes sense right like Wilson Fisk
went to prison he's now gone everybody's
happy except for Bullseye so it's not
too hard to pick up where they lived off
and I don't think they need to Trail too
much with the Netflix story into this
one yeah I think Charlie Cox is right I
think he's probably quoting Kevin feige
accurately and that feige does not want
this to be a season for the Netflix show
explicitly but I think you're right Jess
I think it's gonna Like the Way season
three ended was almost like a return to
the status quo a little bit and like I
think a lot of the fans who watch that
Netflix series I suspect will watch
um we'll watch Daredevil born again and
be able to like connect the dots enough
in their head if you feel like this is
taking place after I think we're still
going to be having this debate over how
connected it is the Netflix one long
after all the episodes of Daredevil born
again come out I think really the
difference is going to be what he's
referring to by saying it's a season one
is it's going to feel like a different
show than the Netflix series did I just
think the fact that it's tied in the MCU
it's going to be more interconnected
with the with the MCU at large right I
think it'd be great if Jen shows up I
think it might be a little bit more
comedic I but he did make some comments
during d23 about whether or not it would
be like a slapstick comedy I don't think
it's going to be that I think it's still
gonna be pretty dark
um yeah but like I just think it's going
to feel like a reset for a lot of people
I don't know if it's gonna feel feel
tonally like a season four but I I just
don't think they're going to like
I think they're just gonna make these
vague comments of like they're just both
actively in their Prime It's Not Gonna
Be An Origin story there's just gonna be
certain things that like they haven't
encountered yet but then they have some
past battles and I don't think the
show's gonna Focus too much on what
those past battles are because you're
right into your right that like they
cannot they cannot like reference
specific Netflix things because then it
would force Disney plus subscribers to
go watch the Netflix show and that's not
in their interest to do that they don't
want to focus on that history that much
I don't know um exactly what the like
the overall like how gruesome this new
Daredevil Born Again series is going to
be because like the Netflix shows like
they got into everything like you know
like like they got really really dark
and like Disney I feel is probably gonna
pull back a little bit and I feel like a
lot of um the audience for the Netflix
Daredevil is gonna be a lot different
from the born again because like they're
probably gonna make it more geared
towards everyone versus you know adults
for Netflix so I feel like there's a lot
of like younger people that probably
haven't even seen Daredevil yet
um so they just probably just want to
reboot in general it's like all right
let's just not reboot but like here's a
new story you don't have to worry about
like the stuff that you didn't see here
it is uh the the Daredevil born is again
uh on Disney plus is gonna begin with
someone impaling their own head on a
spike so that they could avoid the wrath
of Wilson Fisk because that was crazy
that might be the most violent maybe not
the most violent death but like just the
idea behind it that he would do that to
himself like damn just because he'd be
worried about getting his head crushed
in a car door I'd be like give me the
car door please
[Laughter]
oh my God yeah it's pretty pretty
gruesome all right well let's move on to
the rest of the episode before we do
let's thank some friends who sponsored
this episode sleep is important and here
at new rockstars We Trust Helix to
protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world I have a helix
mattress as does MT recently producer
Zach producer John also got some Helix
mattresses Helix sleep has a quiz that
takes you just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you everybody's unique and Helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and fur mattresses mattress
is great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even Helix plus mattress or plus
size sleepers producer Zach took the
Helix quiz and was matched with the
midnight Luxe mattress because he's a
he's a side sleeper that needed a softer
mattress and now he doesn't wake up with
a sore shoulder or neck like he used to
with other mattresses just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
a try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com slash
inside marble all right Mt you've been
very patient and I know that hat can't
be very cool like it's very cool to wear
but like it's got to be warm under there
um yeah so let's talk about it Eugene
patilio is here in the MCU what do you
think is going to be in his involvement
with Jen how is he gonna get in the mix
I think that this dude's going to goof
his way into
um accidentally committing a crime
um I think that he's gonna want to be a
hero
um he's you know he's gonna want to try
to like you know re-um Orient his
family's reputation because his father
in the comics is LeapFrog the villain
he's a villain you uh he's a daredevil
villain who um you know gets into lots
of scrapes and then he retires and he
has a kid and Eugene and he's super
shameful of his life as a as a criminal
and so Eugene's like I want to take my
dad's suit and fight crime like a good
guy and just from his first appearance
in this episode I can tell that he's
gonna be a goofball like he doesn't
really know what he's doing he might I
think he might just evade the law I
think that he might try to run when he
gets arrested and that Daredevil and Jen
are gonna have to chase oh that's so
stupid it would be so fun I think I
agree with you and that's why I was like
I completely think he's lost in that
place because he's never been there
before and he's on an errand picking up
a suit for either I pitched his dad but
it could be anyone but I do think it's
like his dad's suit and he's gonna steal
his dad's suit and just start fighting
crime so it'd be funny if he starts like
fighting crime in his dad's like I have
to send the police after my son for
stealing my house
they think it's me please arrest my son
yeah please arrest my son he stole my
outfit let him sleep it off in jail yeah
let him sleep it off in jail yeah he has
to learn
um do you know you remember how you were
like I think his dad is the guy that
jumps out the window onto the car do you
know if maybe that's why he's like you
think you think Dave pasquesi the uh the
guy who plays the twilik in in Boba Fett
because that's the actor who plays Mt
said I think it's that weird guy in the
third episode that hits on Jen and um
Nikki at the bar I was like I think
that's his dad because I think he's a
weirdo and I think he's after Jen's
blood and he's gonna steal that costume
and be like Jen stay away from my dad
he's trying to steal your butt the
dude's being weird yeah stop dad stop
being please that's a really good
Contender but I definitely feel like
it's the window guy that got the windows
in the window in the trailer and lands
on the car like that seems like a very
least does that in the comics when he
gets uh when he's in court he tries to
evade the law by jumping through the
window and he breaks his ankles it's
quite hilarious I can't wait to see
Eugene do that Eugene's just gonna jump
out the window and break his own ankles
I really want there's so much setup for
him that it's like I I just want him to
be like a rich dummy but then I think
we're getting that with Todd already so
I think like and I know that he is like
poor in the comments I know his or
comments and his Comics I know his dad
was like working stealing and being a
crime person because they needed money
in their family but it's just like I
don't know I don't know what to expect
from LeapFrog or at least Eugene I as he
seems too chaotic I I really hope that
he gets carried over into born again
because like he LeapFrog is a daredevil
villain and like I would love if he were
just like someone that keeps getting
into Matt Murdoch's way he just keeps
showing up he's like yo I could be like
you like me like you like me somebody
Jen introduces him to Daredevil and he
starts working for Daredevil I will love
that please Marvel like he could be like
somebody see I have a feeling I don't
know if uh Eugene's gonna make it out of
the shield series unless he's super
popular unless like once he arrives it's
a huge freaking Splash yo the Frog squad
has been activated of course he's gonna
be popular let's go okay mt's gonna make
sure it happens I just feel like if
anyone is a breakout star only so many
people can be a breakout outside show
and it seems like what do you think it
is the series so far is Madison like
Madison's got her own poster like she
seems to be the hit but we'll see we'll
see I have High Hopes first it's
interesting that's like more there's
there are too many there's too many
cameos there's too many cameos because
it's like if they do have to choose one
it's like you're gonna choose Madison
over like Titania over pug over Nikki
because I I still think Nikki's gonna
die uh but that's a lot I really hope
not I've been dreading it please don't
think he's gonna die Nikki's Gotta Die I
think Nikki's either gonna die or she's
gonna reveal her okay there's three
things Nikki's either gonna die she's
gonna reveal herself to be a witch or
she's actually in love with She-Hulk one
of the three one of the three it's gonna
happen can't she just be a friend in a
confidant
like just a good person a good wholesome
sweetheart in this world why not that
absolutely they just die usually
the best friend when you're the best
friend you got to be the one on the line
yo I will be devastated she dies
devastated oh I'm sorry let's speculate
on on Todd for a second what is Todd's
deal he just seemed like a weirdo on a
date now he's got some like high-powered
attorney repping him he's got a day
scarf is you say a day scarf the thing
around his neck oh my God and indoor
glasses
um so he was like this is my attorney
Mallory is working on both sides she
does not only have to work on the
Superhuman law division correct because
I'm like why is she protecting this guy
why is she oh yeah it's a good point I
think she's been assigned to that
division but she probably has like
grandfathered in some previous kids yeah
some other clients okay makes sense
Todd's just a douche
he's such a butt that I think he's just
gonna do butt things like I didn't like
his Encore when he was straight up just
like I'm a good person girls love me I'm
so nice I'm sweet I was like this is the
formula for a horrible person
um and so I just think he's gonna be
like a
weird like women owe me this they owe me
this I I'm the best that she's ever
gonna get and so I think because of all
that money and bachelor lifestyle he's
just gonna be like a menace an annoying
Menace
and yeah that's what I think I I still
definitely think that um Todd is mad man
I think that he's the leader's brother
and I feel like he just he's he's after
that blood that's why he wanted another
date I feel like he he got all that
Intel from the first date and he's like
all right let me try a vibranium needle
this time we're like let me try this
other needle let me do it um and he's
gonna set her up to try to to get more
of that Hulk blood because he just he
seems very obsessed with the idea of
superheroes I just feel like Todd is
gonna probably end up being the villain
of this whole thing
um sort of like representing the toxic
masculinity of um the world and the
Superhuman form in the 2014 comic run
there was uh a guy that was just like
him and it turned out to be doctor
Doom's son and he was a I don't think
this is Dr Doom's son I don't know if
that's there's so many cameos the last
thing we need is to put in Doctor Doom
I think they might be using that as just
like a uh as a mapping way of using that
issue of that comic it's an like number
two or three of just like this guy and
he was uh annoying he was the worst he
was like so demanding of She-Hulk and
just being like you're on my time I'm
not on yours and I was like you're not
doing anything you're running away from
home so I think they're probably just
kind of like overlaying that guy I think
for me like the future of uh Todd is
like what is the the core relationship
and conflict of the show is it like
about like cousins of superheroes if so
then like yeah I could see Todd being
the cousin of someone important and he's
trying he has somehow inherited
something from a family member a cousin
a father a brother and he's like doing
it on the best of them but just based
off of this moment in this episode where
he's like with Maori book I'm like okay
it doesn't feel like he's someone's
relative it seems like he is he's got
his own personal agenda that's that has
nothing to do with any other superhero
he's he's just a rich nerd who's got a
fascination with Jen and wants her blood
and yeah I but I still think he will be
the villain uh like right just based off
of this the way this episode kind of
puts Titania on the back burner it
really was just like she's just kind of
a societal reflection of the annoyances
that Jen has to deal with but I don't
think she's going to be the big bad of
the show I think the big bad is gonna be
right whoever's paying The Wrecking Crew
and yeah I'm starting to think
especially after the leader got
announced that he's returning in cap
four I really do feel like the leader is
going to be behind this I don't know if
he shows up on the show but maybe we
find out that the intelligencia is who's
funding The Wrecking Crew and these
other people yeah yeah okay one question
I want to leave y'all with is like
should pugs shoes in the credits count
as MCU Cannon
I think that we should take this as a
good sign of the characters that Marvel
has are actively thinking about right
now which is um I'm super excited about
because I I want to see speedball in the
MCU so badly I think it'd be such a
great fit but I just think that these
are all just like the characters I was
like yeah we love like we like these
characters we see the potential in these
characters but like they're not MCU
confirmed this is just like um these
dumb end credits drawings are just like
the court drawings basically
um they're supposed to be modeled after
court so like not it's not all accurate
it's not gonna be all real so it's just
like you don't think courtroom sketch
artists are trying to draw they're doing
that photographers they're not putting
in Wolverine on the in the jury pool
you like to ride surfboards yeah yeah
you like certain pointers
I'm gonna make the other person sit on
top of it they uh they butcher me every
time I do one some models are gonna be
giving me smooches
um
episode of Nathan for you is my favorite
by the way I can't watch Nathan for you
it stresses me out
um I can't watch it
um I think it's interesting it's it's
it's one of those things where like even
with like the Wolverine the bear the
brawl and a CL in a bar kind of thing is
just like these writers which I love to
death because I know two of them
actually do are like one is riding the
new Miles Morales comic book series so
like a lot of the writers for the series
write Comics they know Comics they love
Comics they're just trying to put that
in there that's like it's clear once I
get this in there I can leave like you
guys have to acknowledge it eventually
so I think it's just the writers just
having fun and wanting to acknowledge
that like we love these and we want to
see them too just as much as you do
um well but do real sneakers probably
exist in that world yes I'm sure like
the Iron Man 3's do are probably real
real sneakers just like the moon night
ones will become just like the other
ones will become but it's just like no
one knows Deadpool yet so how does that
shoe exist unless it's based off a comic
book in the yeah or Nova it's like you
no they can't we can't we can't but I'm
sure they do exist yeah if all these
characters were popular enough to like
get shoes modeled after them we would
have heard of them in the EMC they would
have been celebrities like everyone else
so yeah true then empty you're right to
remind us that this is like designed to
be a courtroom artist uh and but like
that's just like the look and the feel
and design of it and we actually see
these drawings come together so it's
some sketch book person who is just like
using their artistic license to just
have some fun and I think that's and
plus like some of these shoes are are
terrorists like we got great goblet
um like some of them
sneakers immediately even if that
villain killed my mother I would be like
I'm buying this soup because this shoe
is sick as hell and I'd be wearing one
for Rockets
your Peter Parker got the ball you see
the [ __ ] Greek goblins
you're wearing the Hulk sneakers and you
go straight to Hell's Kitchen you go hey
look my goddamn sugar oh my look at my
shoes what do you go to like the
people's Graves wearing the shoes what
if you wore that to someone's funeral
that died from like low-key in your
seriously it's like man I had to look
fresh though yeah but Mom these are the
Loki fours they match my they match my
suit
he wears a monastery in that some guys
like that too he that's about two counts
by Grandpa's eye he's on the ground
they're just break dancing like what
about it
my job uh we'll leave it there this
episode of inside Marvel follow Mt at
mastertainment follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clements follow me at eavos
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and be sure to stick around uh Jess's
breakdown of the episode is going to
come out tomorrow so it's gonna be great
she's gonna point out all those shoes
for us it's gonna be awesome and we'll
see you all next week bye everybody
foreign